ó senhor já hoje ouviram falar nesse
senhor fernando pessoa foi o que me
inspirou
está connosco só com carlos morán e os
urinóis daqui estragaram a minha
intervenção os urinóis fizeram passar eu
tenho uma piada mesmo preparar a linha e
todos os homens sabem que já fizeram
antes da partida quando os buracos
terminal ea não sei talvez olhar pro
lado
são cinco são sim aqui neste espaço são
assim
normalmente um certo então o jovem ele
contava piada muito engraçada pessoas e
leiria numa loja minimercado e pacheco
humor está em todo lava e nesse mercado
o dono era surdo mudo e entrou um surdo
mudo e eu estava a assistir e o o o
cliente surdo muito fácil para o outro e
outras fontes e assim era sobre um
pacote canela e outros ponderou em pau e
pau mas não era isso
não não não é isso
o pior é que não é não é isso que eu vou
contar histórias pessoa no urinol hoje
aqui com uma pessoa que está aí e que
nem sabe o que aconteceu mas já lá vamos
chegar que vocês vão descobrir o meu
treino hoje e como você vê que
traumatizado pela primeira vez a mosca
trabalham no bairro
meus amigos eu trago nesta pasta nesta
mala fernando pessoa e vocês vão ter
aqui uma frase que nos vai fazer pensar
em tudo o caso moura como desculpa mas é
exposto nestas terras haver discordância
averba leva isso a sério
não aceitei que eu fiz não vai ter sede
e vou explicar porque estamos num teatro
eu estou no palco você está na platéia
eu estou que um candidato por vocês
todos ppt hoje a primeira vez que eu vi
minha vida
chora estavam todas as refeições olhar
pra mim eu nem sabia que isto é que eu
vou encher da minha vida de prince giras
tem tanta coisa para cuidar sempre o
pacto com o meu gado que talvez que eu
passei os meus filhos que o processo se
encontra melhor porque considera levar
isso a sério
neste ato todos vocês estão aqui entra
no mesmo filme deu entre chamado filme
da vida vocês não pensava que o rir
começa assim paulo na vossa vida que o
rir quando atingiu os outros excluir não
ter residência habita dentro de nós um
dia vão descobrir que nesta peça nós
temos todos que acaba em drama e vamos
todos desta para melhor
saiu daqui a pensar que vão estar muito
tempo mortos para se preocupar
então essa frase é muito importante
eu fui criado ouvir essa frase tem juízo
as portas do mal eu fui muito pior é
minha alcunha de mil eram metralha vocês
não podem imaginar eu avaliá tudo por
tamanho ter boas notas não tinha boas
notas não importava vai então pensar em
ter em colégios internos é certa mas eu
continua a ser assim meus clientes os
clientes os meus livros tudo que eu
faço na vida é porque eu não sou igual
aos outros
assumo que é ser diferente sabe por quê
porque eu sou muito mais engraçado da
ilha teme e mulher vejam ao fim de
tantos anos da prenda um dia perguntei
quando for desta melhor que tu vais ter
soldados e além disso o teu sorriso
condenado a ter que me rir e sorrir que
é o que ela gosta
ainda hoje de manhã eu estava esperando
um sorriso é esse filho da matilha pra
que ficar mais gira tem quando a equipe
começa e ela ficou cobre isso que o povo
quer poder por e ela deixa a gente
sempre nas minhas aulas
sabem por que vocês vão descobrir o
sorrir e os sorrir ao ter estados
fisiológicas altera tudo na nossa vida
focar a atenção quando eu contei aquela
piada a primeira vocês todos sabem qual
o fim que uma piada inocência é conexão
entre aquilo que não nos parece lógico e
nós achamos piada dentro desta nova tem
uma série de coisas a primeira todas é
esta
meus amigos e eu dizer vossa vida com
cenas que deferira porque é muito chato
estar e fazer episódios todos os dias e
86 mil e 451 todos os dias eu consigo
servem e você chegará à noite e não teve
nenhum motivo para rir
por favor hoje à noite na caminha se o
que o ifs primeira vez que o edifício
fevereiro
obrigado por chamar a atenção que
tentava encontrar meus amigos inscrevam
as cenas da vossa vida faça o spekx for
preciso para vocês poderem fazer é uau
foi esse o motivo que uma senhora que
está aqui sentar na frente porque elas
fazem amanhã já foi no século passado
anos nós nos conhecemos nos princípios
nos enrolamos foi a data que marcamos
obrigado obrigado a continuar maquiar
pode ser que estão voltando 6
vai continuar aliás não sei se vocês
sabem o senhor que inventou a cosmética
como se aos meus parcos oficias nós não
vendemos cosmética vendendo esperança
filha portanto continua hoje pra eu né
esta é a primeira coisa que eu queria
ser meus amigos
olhem para a nossa vida como um filme
todos os dias tem 86 mil e quatrocentos
conde e repetitivas e que esta pessoa
está aqui a primeira palavra para dizer
obrigado a servir 83 do vosso dia 0 83%
a vossa vida estão a dar a mim está em
cima de estoques e merecedor 0 83% da
vossa vida para 80 e tudo vamos mostrar
foi exaustivo tudo o que eu vou fazer
foi altamente preparado e eu pensava
como é que vai entrar como é que vai
sair de um trabalho árduo em cima da
mesa a noite preparar uma coisa para vir
até não é fácil amigo e técnico carlos
do carmo o extra gomes tudo isso tem que
ser levado a sério
casamentos esta é minha mascote sempre
com ela
o texto traz uma luva branca paganelli
estou mais feliz sou mais eficaz o mais
concretizador
quando estou feliz uma das frases que
vocês vão ver no meu próximo livro é um
livro maluco começa inclusive assim a
palavra que eu andava à procura desta
palavra
qual é a palavra mais importante em
nossa vida
será que eu descobri compromisso é para
fora nos enche tanto de rosário por aí
mas na véspera que tudo tremeu na hora
tudo tremer âmbito é palavra mas nos
apavora mas ao mesmo tempo - e chita
eu quero que tenha um compromisso com a
vida aceitando se eu tivesse aqui dizia
esta pessoa que vocês vêem aqui à frente
igual a vocês têm sistema nervoso tem
coração tem às vezes fico muito feliz
com os meus olhos
consegui deixar o meu coração sem passar
o filtro do servo princípio da vida me
chamaram maluco porque como eu às vezes
meu cérebro não deixa não ser fez outras
vezes deixam de ser feliz mas eu gosto
muito dessas coisas o porco assim tão
bonito ver a questão do veículo
eu quero ser feliz porque sim cria com
as sessões pensasse nisso hoje à noite
na minha cana eu vou olhar para o teto
não vou pensar na agenda da manhã os
problemas no irs tendo passos coelho nem
na europa
vou pensar só o que hoje tive que me fez
tudo isso o que eu vi hoje na página da
minha vida hoje no meu time eu vou
acordar com prazer escreveu num papel na
agenda as coisas boas da vossa vida o
fim do ano cordas
estávamos em crise do ano passado e
outro e outro e no fim do ano a minha
agenda continua por as coisas a mão e
fui ver 554 momentos que eu gostava de
repetir esse é um dos meus momentos
felizes quando faz alguma coisa que eu
gosto dos truques que pensar sempre joão
que sorte totais há tantos anos teria
desferido em janeiro um sítio o país
implementar nunca experimentar o que faz
aprender nunca aprender depois vitor
nunca vista tem 58 anos só tem pena não
ter cursado strategy 4833 vão lá com 16
30 e thala que eu pensasse voz porque
nós todos
não usamos nossa vida verbas da ação o
rio tem que ser para nós álbum seja o
nosso operador de transformação
tristezas não pagam dívidas estão
produtos existentes em portugal mas
também o país que lhes muito riso pouco
siso que vou ter trabalhado dez anos com
americanos e ensinar é que não sabe
sorrir não é pessoa séria esta que hoje
está aí foi a única altura minha vida em
que juraram e pagaram muito animado
cairá por preços que não sabe sobre uma
pessoa séria foi um pai como fazem os
políticos deus mas também como eu como
os estados unidos como é ser chato ser
aborrecido ser possível falar mal tudo
no vento
não sei vamos ver como está o piloto e
do outro e essa final é melhor ter um
pib gente feliz
gente que tem até uma para duas palavras
que eu tenho uma inveja como eu adorava
por no léxico português sowhat que
publica que o tem problema qualquer
sóchi e nós sempre que os vinhos mais
indo assim olha para o ano pelo menos
que seja olha como esse
por favor você tem que ter como tendo em
casa a televisão tem um comando para nós
neste momento temos
guerra estes produtos tóxicos inocentou
chicão todos os dias
vejam quem é terminar as audiências na
televisão e nos jornais é porque vocês
veem meus damos o que vocês querem vocês
decidir entre o cara e não vê as coisas
que me deprimi mostra que as relações
humanas hoje não valem nada que mostre
que o uso doméstico não são presos muda
internaura a tudo na televisão sempre
isso é bom disse zermeno estamos com 1.2
não estamos dando aos tops assim assim
não desfez tanta publicidade é produtos
contra disfunção erétil sabe porque isso
não funciona quando está ao contrário
festa cabeça não estava em outra não
funciona você pode me era assim
assim sobram por favor a porta a porta
do rio mora em nós
victor hugo diz qualquer coisa deste
género o mayer galhada eu sol mata o
inverno da nossa cara
antónio damásio de sá dias no brasil
cumpre ao público nesta gerações é falta
de esportividade no rosto
são todos membros da mesma sociedade que
os gerados em tempo todo estão nesta
sala sem tempo e agora deve ficar nas
sociedades cansados que temos com gestos
tudo eu fico doido quando foi alguma
escola mil habitantes têm até a
quantidade compromisso que eu tenho é
quando que parece tudo neste momento
estou a ficar cansado com o chefe coisa
espontânea e então tem que aprender uma
coisa ser inteligente é também saber o
que deve ignorar e como tristezas não
pagam dívidas
eu vou optar por esta solução quero ir a
esta porta é fácil
é muito fácil como vetar o nó sabem às
vezes nota muito confortável não quero
tratá-lo quero mandar o aço o laço a
vossa vida que decidirem aqui e agora
porque o pensamento é físico não há
ninguém nesta sala e não seja capaz de
pensar bem de mim como alguém qualquer
um de vocês
isto é prova de que o pensamento é
físico qualquer um de vocês estou a
pensar bem ou mal de tudo na vida esse
poder tem que ser nosso e
posso ver o lado positivo das coisas eu
posso ver o lado negativo só com
negativa ativa aqui traz uma coisa
chamada cortisol da capa do meu sistema
imunitário e na casa de mim e eu não
tenho direito de importar uma vida que
foi oferecida certo portanto decidir se
os estilos o talo provável transformação
e rir começa qualquer coisa quando o rio
é impossível o regime não acontecer nada
este é o nosso serviço pino e se nós
quisermos virar sem vontade nenhuma
certo passado um bocado como eu vou
fazer com vocês já vão ver o rio está
dentro de nós então os amigos
o último livro que escreveu esta será
que o conceito a mim quem exatamente
isso nós temos programados temos um
software é maravilhoso que chamasse
emoções básicas e que os protesto faz
com que estejamos vivos só que o grande
problema e aquelas são assimétricas para
nos proteger são mais negativas do que
positivas catarino medo
a primeira coisa que nossos pais se
empenharam nos ensinar a não faz pra mim
não faz isso não me ensinasse a ter medo
de morrer rapidamente certo onde um nojo
só se eu tivesse ido longe dentro nós
comemos coisas estragadas coisas
a raiva é da silva testou a gente não
pode ser
depois temos a alegria tem tonito
alegria por um estado de ânimo mas tom
da emoção básica que todos têm chamada
surpresa positiva e gera nos outros
indiretamente satisfação e vontade
envolver tanto uma piada uma piada
o radar piada e agora posso contar só o
senhor nesta sala que viu isto que o
fato de moscas nos urinóis estudou todo
meu discurso quando eu fui original num
desses intervalos
eu só saí está um senhor sozinho aqui
neste cantinho
não sei que eu tava com medo trabalho
tanto tempo sozinho claro à boa maneira
portuguesa eu fui pra outra ponta estava
mostrando original como costuma estar
assim proponho pilatinhos habitava os
dias todas na fila e eu é que agora
todos que estavam no seu interior não há
fila mas não eu entrei por ano
e quando eu estou como ambrose fora a
cansar ordinária é mostrando a inter é
viva e houve um só senhor assim e começa
a beijar o chão
o homem não tem explicação eu tô aqui
imagine o que é o envio de estar ou
tanto a urinar e ver um indivíduo pediu
asprilla assim ordinário sparta não sabe
o que eu fiz e música
agora amigo está enfrentado alguns sabem
a música levantou na ilha e outros times
no domingo
o que eu fiz está a a exatamente aquilo
que miguel sousa miguel esteves cardoso
diz um dia irei bom não herde isso é ter
uma parte e se tenha enfrentado maioria
dos outros não errei porque isso carlos
moura e com o porto ele em princípio ele
nos faz bem e liberta endorfinas vocês
vão ver a pessoa foi a seguir como ela
vai explicar cientificamente é
importante
meus amigos pois temos uma coisa
desculpa pois tem uma coisa importante a
lei que é o rio da descoberta
quem são as mulheres que estão aqui
dentro que não vão concordar com isso
ele só pode esconder o mas é o que eles
mais gostam temam que israelense prazer
e gosto do terreiro esticavam mais do
que o ter incluído só para longas
eu tenho aqui a minha resposta é para
uso de mouse
o que é que as mulheres gostam têm na
mão todas então estiver calor gostam a
não sejam mal não seja mau
jantando eram até eu já fiquei assim a
quando uma missa assim é também um batom
também carregam button também já tem
aqui um batom
meus amigos o fato passou agora um tempo
só ontem pinto 70 anos que eu tenho a
cabeça tronco e membros
até ver esta coisa eu sou muito
português
até meu telemóvel no cemar phone esta
coisa de uma inteligência artificial da
cec biônico permite mais 200 vezes por
dia por lá
já tive que fazer com que vocês já estão
todos kaká teve uma fotografia vocês já
está no facebook
quando você estava aqui dançar com a
nossa amiga
bater todos fritos já está lá nisso
hoje temos uma influência foi oficial
que nos permite estar conectados com o
mundo conectados com a sociedade então
temos vontade de rir
vemos o efeito ea procurando coisas por
aí também podemos por aqui os jogos para
desfazer os gajos de projetar os gaúchos
também podemos por aqui os lembradas
temos por aqui toda a bateria
a decisão é nossa só que agora meus
amigos não há desculpas da sadc bionics
temos duas influências temos duas formas
de ver a vida e temos uma ajuda
fantástica podemos civis por estar aqui
devemos olhar pra lipo é que lá a
fantástica contemplação contemplar o
poder que nós temos contagiar os outros
no nosso país e querem ver basta você
fazer esta mensagem coragem com outra
palavra que não aceitaram a minha
sugestão português escrevesse coragem
com um levantar o dito cujo e em dar
certo e esse é a mensagem que os deixou
aqui antes de nos convidar é tentar e
não rir em tentar não rir o que vai
aparecer ali que seria algo vocês
conseguem não se deixar contagiar por
sal vão conseguir não rir com o pai por
ser ali por favor
o médico
ae
mix
este é o meu sonho este é o meu convite
porque a vida é curta demais pra nós
entregarmos a vida às mãos de rotina
só há duas formas de nós mudarmos nós
nos transformamos o melhor operador
transmissão da nossa vida
chama se eu quero porque há um outro que
é o tamanho que o tanque o que era
garante uma coisa se vocês quiserem
vencer algo que habita dentro de vocês e
pensarem que tem cadeado ao máximo esse
fim que todos nós teremos um dia eu
posso garantir uma coisa basta nós
pensarmos como podíamos ter um país 10
milhões e meio de habitantes felizes e
contentes e ser o país dos sorrisos
basta experimentei isto cada vez de
passarem por uma pessoa sorri aí eu
positivo no vosso no facebook deste
evento e ofereço um automóvel uma viagem
que vocês quiserem
no dia em que surgirem para o espanhol e
os pais não vos vou ver o sorriso do
fórum em que o pago
obrigado
ó